why does snoop dogg carry an umbrella
for drizzle
so heavy spoilers is doing a
spoiler-free review
yes i know and whilst i try and avoid
these like the plague
which actually might not be a good
simile saying is how people are avoiding
it
i just had to talk about the umbrella
academy season 2.
i've got a full laundry list of things
that i'm not allowed to discuss
but what i can say is that season 2
is somehow somehow actually better than
the first season
now though this is a spoiler-free review
in order to talk about things
we have to all talk about things so if
you want to go in as blind as possible
then bail out now
none of these things will ruin the show
i don't think but they will give you an
idea of what's going on in it
so yeah i don't want to see no crying
because i told you about things that
happened in the first episode
i will of course be doing a full season
2 breakdown later in the week so
if you don't want to miss that then make
sure you smash the subscribe button
now the season picks up immediately
after the events of the first entry
with the family traveling back through
time to try and stop the apocalypse
number five it did warn everyone that
going back in time was risky
and it turns out that he was right as it
scatters the group across the early 60s
and once more leads to the apocalypse
only this time it's much earlier
so once more the group have to band
together in order to stop it
and also decide whether they want to
give up the lives that they built in the
past
now the season is a loose adaptation of
the second graphic novel called dallas
but even if you've read that the show
still has some surprises in store
even though i've read most of the
original works there were some things
that i'd forgotten about that pop back
up and they were just big reveals that
made me want to keep binging this
over and over again the season is 10
episodes long
roughly weighing in at 45 minutes a
piece but even then
the pacing is incredible and they pack
the run with so many interesting reveals
that it's difficult not to get swept up
in it
because each character has been scared
throughout the time period
sometimes raging from years apart they
have to sort of survive in the past
and thus they build their own lives and
these new opportunities
allow us to discover what the characters
would be like if they actually got the
chance to be normal
in the first season i really felt that
some just got swept to the side
including diego and allison however here
we get to see what they would have
really been like had they not had all
the crazy things happen in their lives
now these elements are in the trailer so
i think that i can talk about them
but each character goes on a really
interesting arc
diego goes off the deep end and is put
into an asylum
due to him trying to stop events in the
past but he gets a fully fleshed out arc
and goes way beyond the sort of batman
parody that he was originally
alison also settles into her new life
initially
being quite subservient before stepping
up to the forefront of a civil rights
movement
she kind of wrestles with whether to use
her powers or not
and arguably has what i'd say is the
most human arc in the entire season
bonya also retreats from things and with
the character that had the most
complicated arc in the first season
they kind of build upon what she
actually wants in life rather than how
she was sort of railroaded down a
certain path
like how she was with hargreaves i think
ellen page probably had
a lot of influence on how vonya's arc is
handled but
what they do with her works really well
and it actually makes a lot of sense in
context with the first season
she was a character that didn't really
get to have a family the first time
around
and this time she's sort of trying to do
whatever she can to keep together the
one that she creates in the past
it's really gripping and once more ellen
page completely nails the role
now luther becomes a fighter for a mob
boss and klaus a cult leader
the scenes that he gets are absolutely
hilarious and
they also have some amazing music to
them too
klaus and ben have a sort of double act
together where the former is making
these
outlandish statements and the latter is
sort of winking at the audience as if to
say
look how stupid this all is which i
think works really well
klaus is one of those unique characters
that only comes along once in a blue
moon
and there's not really a bad scene with
him in the entire season
he actually tries to right one of the
wrongs from the first season
and seeing the struggle that he goes
through being unable to change anything
whilst also being worshipped as a god is
a really really good watch
now i have to say that out of the bunch
five shines the most
i think people will walk away from this
entry with him being their favorite
character eden gallagher who plays the
role has an extremely bright future
ahead of him
and once more he manages to capture the
presence of an old man
stuck in a young boy's body to great
effect five is
sort of the driving force of the season
and whilst everyone gets their own arcs
and lives
he's the one who comes in and brings him
all together also he gets to do some of
the
the glorious things in the season i
think by about the second episode
you start to see him as the leader over
luther because he's just such a dynamic
character
i think it just goes to show how good a
season can be if the casting is correct
which i feel is throughout this season
from the core group to the additional
characters
which i'm not allowed to really talk
about here because netflix will
shoot me don't tell them now time travel
story lines are some of my favorite
things to watch
and read and i think that they did an
incredible job with what was here
every character feels serviced and
because it's set in the past
they also get to interact with a lot of
key characters not only from the show's
history
but from our history itself this leads
to a lot of cool
easter eggs that i think fans of the 60s
will definitely enjoy
fans of the 50 so get the get the bloody
hell out here
now hog grooves is back and though we
learned very little about him in the
first season
that's completely changed here initially
we were told that he was an olympic
gold medalist inventor architect
probably youtuber crappy crappy youtuber
just like his hero definition
and whatever other strings he had to his
bow but here we get to see firsthand how
he must have accomplished these
and how he may have had more sinister
goings on in the past
one day i would actually love to see a
hargreaves prequel show or to have him
as a full main character
as he's just that interesting the
soundtrack is incredible too
and whether it's golden brown or a cover
of billy eilish
the music is used a great effect to add
a lot of weight to the action
scenes and things on screen i know show
is perfect
and i think that where season two is let
down is in its villains
there are actually three swedish
triplets from the temps commission
are trying to erase the group from
history and their mute for the most part
just showing up to cause some trouble
whenever the show needs them to
to ramp up the action a bit they do
introduce new villains such as
carmichael
aka the talking goldfish and though he's
interesting to look at
i think you will probably have the
memory of a goldfish when you think
about how much he brought to the season
sorry that that that joke was atrocious
now on top of this
the finale is a bit sort of left field
with what they do with some characters
and personally
i feel like they could have ended the
season one episode earlier
and not had some of the moments where
where they jumped the shark
or rather goldfish sorry ruined it again
however they do pull it back round
and it tease more things for season
three which i'm definitely
excited for i probably made that all
sound worse than it really is
as i'm just trying to create a balanced
review and
it's the family that takes the main
focus which is definitely how it should
be as
they're clearly the most interesting
parts in conclusion
all of them get really well developed
arcs and feel
fascinating to watch i really hope that
kevin feige is just sat
scribbling down notes from this for
their inevitable x-men
reboot as this is how this story should
be done we don't constantly see the
powers being used all of the time
and this is because the story of the
group takes center stage
which in my opinion is how it should be
handled you could quite easily strip the
superhero elements out of this
and still have a really interesting plot
which is a complement to how well
everything is developed and handled
in summary as i said earlier this is
better than the first season
in every single way the story is better
the characters are better
the acting works a lot better better
better better
bye bye my butter overall the season was
an incredible ride from start to finish
i think that after this the umbrella
academy will be cemented as one of not
only the best series on netflix
but one of the best comic book tv shows
of all time
it's just that good umbrella academy was
phenomenal
and it gets a 9.5 out of 10.
okay so i'd absolutely love to hear
whether you hyped or not
and what other superhero tv shows you
love and think are worth checking out
make sure you comment below and let me
know and if you want something else
comic book related to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of the
new snyder cut clip and panel that
happened over the weekend at justice con
we talk about all the ins and outs of
things that were revealed and it's
definitely
worth watching if you want to know more
about the movie don't forget that every
month on the 15th we give away free
blu-rays
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning the mcu infinity
soccer box set is leave a like
subscribe with notifications on and drop
your thoughts on the umbrella academy
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
it massively helps us out and you get
access to content early
you can also come chat to us on our
discord server link below or heavy
spoilers on twitter
if not then thank you for making it
until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition and i'll see you next time
take care peace
you